[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi siete domandati cosa ci facesse un
mattoncino come questo nella borsa che
vi è stata consegnata
prendetelo
è un semplice mattoncino O almeno lo
sembra
simboleggia il muro di un edificio molto
particolare
e vorrei raccontarvi la sua storia
8 agosto 2018 sono a longbok in
Indonesia per le mie vacanze estive
vacanze Sognate da tempo un posto
paradisiaco un hotel meraviglioso
pensate che quel giorno avevo notato per
la prima volta con le tartarughe in un
mare cristallino
mi sto preparando per la cena con mio
marito
quando la terra inizia a tremare
forte fortissima
è un terremoto
nel tempo di poterci riparare sotto un
tavolo come ci avevano insegnato da
piccoli a scuola
dura pochi secondi non tempo infinito un
tempo che non passa mai
una volta terminato riusciamo ad uscire
dalla nostra stanza
faccio un po' fatica ad aprire la porta
perché si è deformata durante il
terremoto Ma sono talmente concentrata a
raggiungere il punto di raccolta che non
ci faccia più di tanto caso
ben presto scopriamo che anche gli altri
ospiti dell'hotel sono tutti sani e
salvi
attorno a noi Però regna la distruzione
scopriremo solo qualche giorno più tardi
che la conta delle vittime supera le 500
persone
come potete immaginare
attorno a noi gli edifici sono ridotti
in macerie
macerie proprio come questo mattoncino
in quel momento sia che mio marito
volevamo fare qualcosa renderci utili ma
in primo momento ci sentiamo impotenti
perché ho fatto ingegneria di le
architetture perché ho fatto un
dottorato nella digitalizzazione del
settore delle costruzioni Perché invece
non ho studiato medicina per poter
aiutare chi ha veramente bisogno i
momenti come quello
poi quando torna la lucidità ti accorgi
invece e ti rendi conto dell'importanza
del loro del ruolo dell'ingegnere e
dell'ingegnere come sono e di chiunque
lavori nel settore delle costruzioni
Perché sì i medici possono salvare vite
a tragedia avvenuta Ma gli ingegneri
possono evitarle
non solo ti rendi conto anche
dell'importanza dei dati di come i dati
possono aiutare ognuno di noi a fare
delle decisioni ogni giorno
i dati nel settore delle costruzioni ci
possono aiutare per sapere se gli
edifici sono sicuri
Quanta energia consumano se sono
sostenibili
se sapeste che i muri della vostra casa
non sono ben isolati e di spendono molte
energia e questo incide notevolmente
sulla bolletta fine mese non valutereste
di chiamare qualcuno per risolvere il
problema
se sapeste che la scuola dei vostri
figli non è sicura
non ne Sceglieresti un'altra
se sapeste che il ponte che volete
attraversare non è stato mantenuto da
decenni non valuteresti un altro
percorso
i dati ci permettono di fare delle
scelte consapevoli
dati in tempo reale
in altre Industrie come quella
dell'automotive i sensori sono
installati Ormai in tutte le nostre auto
sensori di prossimità per il parcheggio
sensori di pressione delle gomme
Ecco questo nel settore delle
costruzioni ancora raramente accade
il settore delle costruzioni non so se
sapete quando parliamo di
digitalizzazione E in fondo alla
classifica
e praticamente ultimo prima solo
dell'Agricoltura ma ci rendiamo conto
Tuttavia è un settore assai importante
non solo perché ci dà un tetto sopra le
nostre teste ma ci dà anche gli edifici
Dove possiamo studiare uffici Dove
possiamo lavorare strade per muoverci
Ma sapete In quale percentuale il
settore delle costruzioni è responsabile
per le missioni di CO2
il settore delle costruzioni e
responsabile per il 40% di emissioni di
CO2 40% vi rendete conto
cioè un settore così impattante
praticamente ultimo nella
digitalizzazione non è assurdo
vi faccio un esempio
se pensiamo a una struttura con di un
capannone con una struttura di acciaio
Ecco questo allo stesso impatto di 5.000
voli da Milano a New York
Dobbiamo quindi migliorare il modo in
cui gestiamo i dati ognuno di noi può
contribuire dobbiamo migliorare i dati
nelle diverse fasi delle costruzioni
durante la progettazione quando
realizziamo la nuova opera o meglio
quando la ristrutturiamo durante la
costruzione quando la realizziamo E
durante la fase di gestione come la
manteniamo una volta realizzata
tutto questo oggi è possibile grazie a
una nuova metodologia chiamata
building information modeling
il building information modeling ci
permette di creare dati dati che diversi
utenti ognuno di noi può utilizzare per
sapere la qualità degli ambienti in cui
viviamo se le scuole dei nostri figli
sono sicure se i ponti che vogliamo
percorrere sono stati mantenuti
questa metodologia adesso è obbligatoria
Ormai in diversi paesi in Italia è
obbligatoria per tutte le opere sopra i
15 milioni di euro e dal 2025 sarà
obbligatoria per tutte le opere sopra il
milione di euro
Quindi ognuno di noi può richiedere
questa metodologia immaginate di avere
la possibilità sul vostro telefono di
avere l'informazione dei dati degli
edifici e delle Infrastrutture che usate
e quindi essere avvisati se qualcosa non
funziona proprio accade come una spia di
una di una macchina che ci informa che
dobbiamo far controllare la nostra auto
Ecco questi dati sono disponibili
possiamo utilizzarli come quando
Richiediamo le informazioni per quando
compriamo un elettrodomestico un auto
questa metodologia può essere veramente
innovativa
nel caso del terremoto in Indonesia
aveva permesso a molte persone di
scegliere un hotel sicuro scelte basate
sui dati
e quindi fare la differenza tra la vita
e la morte
Ma siamo sicuri che digitalizzare tutto
quello che ci circonda sia sempre un
bene
siamo sicuri che la tecnologia
sia sempre usata per noi e non contro di
noi
Chi di voi ha mai ricevuto una
pubblicità sul proprio telefono di
qualcosa di cui aveva solamente parlato
senza averla cercata direttamente a chi
di voi è successo non siete timidi Ok un
buon numero anche a me è successo in una
serata con amici dovevo fargli
indovinare una canzone quella di
Battiato Cerco un centro di gravità
permanente
e il giorno dopo prendendo il cellulare
e guardando su YouTube Indovinate qual è
stato il primo video che mi è stato
suggerito
Eh sì proprio quello di Battiato Cerco
un centro di gravità permanente un caso
Purtroppo no
eri saputo che i dispositivi di
riconoscimento vocale
ascoltano le nostre conversazioni
quanti dati forniamo senza neanche
rendercene conto Magari solo per
attivare la nostra canzone preferita o
il timer in cucina
Ma ne siamo consapevoli
la tecnologia
non è neutra
è stato dimostrato che dispositivi di
riconoscimento facciale
discriminano le persone di colore
che i dispositivi per la trascrizione
automatica dei discorsi riconoscono
meglio quanto detto da un uomo rispetto
da quanto detto da una donna
che i dispositivi di intelligenza
artificiale hanno segnato voti più alti
agli studenti delle scuole private
rispetto a quelli delle scuole pubbliche
la tecnologia non è neutra
vogliamo quindi
circondarci di sensori che rilevano i
nostri comportamenti e quelli degli
edifici che utilizziamo
adesso forse la risposta è no perché mio
babbo ho paura di questa tecnologia di
questa tecnologia che avesse Può essere
usata contro di noi e non per noi
Tuttavia abbiamo visto che i dati
possono fare la differenza possono
salvare delle vite umane
Quindi la risposta alla mia domanda è Sì
vogliamo digitalizzare il settore delle
costruzioni
ma lo vogliamo solo Se questo accade in
una maniera etica
solo se la tecnologia i dati vengono
utilizzati per aiutarci a prendere delle
decisioni consapevoli sulla qualità
degli ambienti in cui viviamo la
sicurezza della scuola dei nostri figli
quella dei ponti che vogliamo percorrere
e non per essere venduti a qualcuno che
ha un interesse a venderci un prodotto
o una ideologia
Che fine faremo Se continuiamo a
permettere che i dati vengono usati
senza il nostro permesso
la prossima volta che scegliamo la
scuola dei nostri figli
Richiediamo dati basati sui modelli
digitali e sui sensori
informiamoci che la tecnologia sia stata
usata eticamente
supportiamo iniziative per la
digitalizzazione di piani di
manutenzione e di rischio delle
Infrastrutture ma pretendiamo che questi
dati siano usati in modo etico
Installiamo dei sensori nelle nostre
abitazioni per capire i consumi
Ma informiamoci che questi dati siano
usati eticamente
supportiamo iniziative che mettano
l'etica al centro dello sviluppo
tecnologico
i dati ci possono permettere di
affrontare la crisi climatica in un
settore come quello del costruzioni che
abbiamo visto essere molto impattante ci
possono permettere di azzerare gli
sprechi
vogliamo che i dati come tanti piccoli
mattoncini ci possono permettere di
costruire un futuro migliore
non vogliamo costruire solo con i
mattoni o che materiali edilizi ma anche
con i dati
qui non stiamo parlando di social o di
qualcosa a cui possiamo rinunciare con
facilità
Qui stiamo parlando del nostro futuro di
quello dei nostri cari
e se è vero che i dati possono fare la
differenza
allora ognuno di noi può e deve
pretendere che i dati siano usati in una
maniera etica Grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]